how did it all go so wrong so
the heart of the issue is the credential
i mean if if you want to take a broad
brushstroke and
um sort of understand what's actually
going on it's the credential
we've seen education be democratized i
mean right now available to every
listener on this program today for
free is a is an ivy league education
between
edx and the mooc platforms and oer
resources
if you are dedicated and hard-working
you can go get yourself an ivy league
education today for free
and yet that hasn't brought down the
price um
that these institutions are charging and
you know it's interesting as we come to
kovit it's a it's a good revelation
of what is going on but you have to ask
where is the value
held and a majority
of the value is held in the actual
credential
and there is value held in other parts
and i think that's what people are
seeing with kovid which is you start to
pull apart
the pieces and is a big bundle
people are willing to pay 200 thousand
dollars for it
but you start pulling you know the
pieces apart and saying
is this piece worth you know what to me
and one of the biggest revelations
is that what you pay for in education is
not the learning
the learning is available today for free
online
what you are paying for are other things
primarily the credential
but people are just waking up to that
because all of a sudden they're on a
zoom call with a professor and 30 other
people
and being charged 16 000 for the
pleasure
so when one looks at that the
other thing that's causing this
revelation is that the experience
of college people frequently say hey the
experience is part of what you're paying
for and the network
so this unbundling the pandemic has
forced people to recognize the
components and it has
in fact unbundled the component so the
experience is gone
the networking is gone and what's left
is
the mooc the massively uh massively open
online course
which we actually had daphne kohler who
co-founded coursera on the program
talking about incitro as the first of
the next unicorn guest
that's what's actually happened here and
what you're saying
is that the component of the course
at an ivy league school is freely
available already so what people were
paying for is not that
and when people do pay 16 000 for
something that is available for free
they get pretty irate and their eyes
open up and they say there has to be a
better way correct
correct yeah so uh when we look at this
post pandemic one question
on that why if all of this ivy league
education is available for free
and it has been for i think getting
close to a decade now
uh since edx and coursera started
putting their stuff online
why have people in america
not realize this and
absolutely swarmed on the mit
free education the harvard free
education the stanford free education
done the coursework
printed out their homework and when they
go for a job hand it to the
potential uh employer
why has that happened so let me let me
ask you a question
tell me about your education if you ask
if you ask anyone that question
tell me about your education 99 of the
people will tell you where they went to
university or what degree they have
and it's an absurdity but it's a good
reflection
of the absurdity of the world we we sort
of find ourselves in
and um it's a reflection of our
inability
to answer any other way if i say tell me
about your education
and you start saying well you know three
years ago i took this course and you
know i got mentored by so and so and
then i had this great project
we we just it's hard to contextualize
there's no universal language
as we you know have to talk about um
the messy process of education and
that's where heuristics and credentials
um step in they give us a language with
which to
convey and to speak about our education
but the world's only universal
credential the only universal language
is that of the college degree
and let's be and so let's be sincere
here uh
and cynical at the same time it's also a
way to
sort of give an indication of your
status and your cast
in life i went to yale you went to brown
this person went to harvard this person
went to fordham somebody else went to
cuny it is a way to signal status
correct the credentials the actual
associates or bachelors bachelors
of science in economics and yet we
usually answer with
where we went to universities um the
logos
yeah because that brand is as much
of what conveys the the information as
the actual
um credential in the actual degree you
know and how we
how we get past this is we need that
the the job to be done we shouldn't
resent it if
i do at times need to know about your
skills i need to know
whether or not you're educated and in
what and what your capabilities are and
what your knowledge is
like we have that need if i'm going to
hire you i have that need if i'm going
to staff you on a project if we're going
to team up
i have that need we shouldn't resent the
need but we just need a better way
of being able to communicate and answer
for it if we're going to get past this